good evening members and officers of the
council I welcome you to this meeting of
the council and welcome to members of
the public in the gallery housekeeping
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices via the stairs either
through the security doors to the right
or opposite the lifts in the foyer
please do not use the lifts please
assemble in Hawley square on the green
officers will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber the Proceedings of this meeting
will be recorded and subsequently
broadcast on the Internet would everyone
present please ensure their mobile
phones are turned to silent and that
they are not used to make or receive
phone calls in the chamber whilst this
meeting is in progress we've missed the
bit about filming does anyone wish to me
film this evening thank you in that case
I haven't got the script in front of me
but if anyone doesn't wish to be caught
on camera then they should leave the
chamber and I would remind those filming
that if there are any children which I
can't see in the public gallery they
should refrain from including those in
any of their frames thank you agenda
item 1 apologies for absence apologists
have been received from the following
councillors councillor Bainbridge Keith
Coleman cook Curran Edwards Evans shank
and Hillman are there any other
apologies for absence mrs. chairman our
councillors della a Glenn Coleman cook
Grove and tenant councillor Piper did I
see your hand up Thank You mr. chairman
council boy Potts thank you agenda item
2 declarations of interest are there any
declarations of interest
in that case we can move on to the main
agenda item which is agenda item free
revisions to delegations I call upon mr.
house director of corporate governance
and monitoring officer mr. house
Thank You German this report is brought
to Council following the decision on the
15th of October not to declare a vacancy
in the Margate Central Ward that
position is untenable because it places
accounts in breach of its statutory
obligations to declare a vacancy in
order to move matters forward the
proposal before members tonight is to
delegate the authority for declaring
vacancies arising under Section 86 of
the local map 1972 to the chief
executive thank you chairman thank you
in that case I propose that council
amends its scheme of delegations by
delegating to the chief executive and in
her absence the director of corporate
corporate governance the authority to
declare vacancies in office under
Section 86 of the Local Government Act
1972 with the vice chairman please
second second nature councillor
baybridge okay thanks chairman I'd like
to move an amendment please in looking
at the the proposal
it does seem illogical to me that if
we're delegated to the chief executive
that's in her absence it's the director
of corporate governance that is the
passage too so I would like to propose
that in fact the substitution for the
chief executive is the deputy chief
executive so my amendment takes the
proposal as printed but deletes director
of corporate governance and inserts
deputy chief executives thank you thank
you
counselor do members agree oh sorry
do I have a seconder yes second it here
Genki councillor savage do members agree
with the amendment
in that case I'll go to the vote all
those members sorry mr. chair I'm sorry
this is a vote on the amendment well
yeah except you haven't invited my point
is that you haven't invited even a
debate or comment for anybody else you
move straight from a proposal to a
singular to a vote our Authority D's in
comfortable position to offer the
decision and discussion for an amendment
for debate in that case we'll debate and
we are debating the amendment
so we're debating the amendment yes
counselor it was for clarification
before you went to the leader of the
council which is your wont to do before
you see anybody else's hands you start
if mr. Howard started his preamble by
immediately referring to Margate central
I'm sorry but we're not over the six
months of bringing an item back if he
had not referred to Margate central in
his preamble I would have gone ahead
with tonight's meeting but I'm afraid we
discussed this matter very recently on
the fifteenth of October and we should
not be discussing Margate central
vacancy for another six months
thank you sorry we are not discussing
the Margot central vacancy you're quite
right what was interesting is a
delegation of powers the executive and
the deputy executive I was merely
explaining how we got to this position
thank you right can we watch the debate
the amendment
council this council walkie
thank you good evening first of all I'd
just like to say that you know why why
was councilor Venables accepted not
relevant
sorry we're debating the agenda items
that's that's that's not relevant and we
really don't want any reference to other
issues Calabrian thank chair
roderick and we just should go straight
to a recorded vote
councillor feller was next thank you I
would just like to say that for me this
amendment doesn't really change anything
that is at debate tonight considering
the delegation of power to a non elected
member so I will be voting against this
amendment Thank You councillor Campbell
don't see your hand on
oh yeah thank you chair yes just it's
about the the vote the viability of a
post of deputy chief executive I mean if
we're actually delegating to the deputy
chief executive there was a time not so
long ago when we actually got rid of the
post there was no deputy chief executive
whereas the original proposition is to
oppose that constantly a must by law or
exists now the problems that we could
have faced if we do delegate to the
deputy chief executive at a later date
we might actually decide that we do not
need to check deputy executive anymore
as we have done quite recently in the
past therefore I think that what we're
doing is we're put in a council into a
situation that is less stable than it
would be under the original proposition
I think councilor Johnson and then
councilor matter phase council Johnson
thank you very much for allowing me to
come back we have a constitutional
working party and usually when such
decisions and amendments are required
they go to the Constitution
working party they then go to the
Standards Committee and if we endorse
them they then come to full council in
all my experience that has been the
system of this council the purpose of a
monitoring officer is to endure
obviously lawfulness and fairness and
what we have seen recently in this
council is anything but fair to the
electorate in my ward I will not go into
detail despite the fact the monitoring
officer has referred wondering I will be
wandering in may thank you very much but
I'm not wondering tonight but I think is
this amendment was thrown very well
quickly and to scupper us I will be
opposing the amendment and I will be
imposed opposing in its entirety giving
such strong delegations to one officer
which could affect all of us all 56 of
us as councillors where we wouldn't know
why someone was disqualified we wouldn't
know why a vacancy was declared we have
always been able to declare a vacancy in
a casual vacancy at full council if
needed but there would always be an
explanation we haven't been doing it in
recent we wind up is that if you need to
know there's a vacancy you have to look
on the board outside in the window
outside I'm totally opposed to the
amendment which is obviously are you
referring to the amendment council you
seem to be wondering if the original
proposition failed there'll be no need
for an amendment the amendment is to try
and scoper us voting on the main tech
the text of this which I'm totally
opposed to councillor Campbell did you
want to come back in that case sorry
counselor matter face Thank You chair
but my point hasn't been adequately
covered by councillor Johnson Thank You
councillor
Piper and then councillor wilt Thank You
mr. chairman just on this amendment and
perhaps I could ask for a clarification
if the amendment has passed I'm not
quite sure I understood my colleagues
comments if the amendment is passed we
still have to go back to the substantive
issue don't we okay on the amendment
only it seems to me personally to make
perfect sense to have a legal mind which
is no disrespect of chief executive but
I have no idea whether she's legally
trained or not it would seem to make as
cancer Campbell says perfect sense to
have a legal officer as the fallback
position if I could put it that way but
I'm speaking solely to the amendment
counsel wills oh yes miss chairman thank
you I'm glad we had a debate it hasn't
been terribly informative
I've sound fairly relaxed about the
amendment it is clearly the local
government equipment of rearranging the
deck chairs on the Titanic thank you
yes counselor Bassett sorry
Thank You chairman I mean I get called
lots of things slippery is a fairly
recent one but there was no intention to
do that I mean this row is this
amendment right simply because a number
of people contacted me and suggested
that it was kind of a logical that if we
have a ditch he's the chief executive in
the absence of chief exec if that person
carries out the function she would have
carried out and to be quite honest I
don't see how a legal mind is necessary
in this because what we're talking about
here is a legally required
administrative function that takes place
when de facto a vacancy arises so I'm
really not sure what all the fuss is
about
but there you go right in that case
we'll vote on the amendment general I do
believe counselor didn't mention a
recorded vote I don't know whether you
wanted to actually put that to council
wasn't second it wasn't seconded so
those in favor of the amendment
okay let's add me to that Thank You
against
abstentions
so the amendment is lost will now go
back to the main proposition do
councilors want me to read it again okay
I thought you'd like to hear my dulcet
tones so I propose that council men's
its scheme of delegations by delegating
to the chief executive and in her
absence the director of corporate
governments the authority to declare
vacancies in office under Section 86 of
the Local Government Act 1972 that's
already been seconded so we can move
straight to the vote or do we want to
debate that one as well
counsel Campbell I thank you yes I will
not be supporting this proposition I do
not pretend to know the reason why 26
members voted against the adversative
agency in Margate central even though
the vast majority will have different
political parties but I assume like me
they believe that injustice had occurred
and that the appropriate process and
practice had not been followed and that
the councillor disqualified to be
unjustly and therefore I believe that in
these circumstances the decision to
announce a vacancy should remain the
decision of full council and not
delegated to officers okay that sir
thank you mister Thank You councillor
that wasn't to the agenda item but yes
Council are key what so really puzzled
me is that belly bores no no we're not
talking about there's totally different
that we're talking to that's nothing to
do with the item on the agenda this
evening
that's a toast a toast Orie that's a
totally different matter no no no no no
no no not so councillor Constantine well
I have to say that I believe our
democracy is being undermined here I
can't see how an unelected officer can
make an implement a unilateral decision
to declare a vacancy when as we've seen
that vacancy might be called in error
and to have the temerity to request
elected May
to help clean up the mess I think is a
disgrace and I've been told by email
that I could be taken to court for my
legitimate vote and I think that's quite
wrong and I think we need to be sure
that we don't undermine our basic
democracy Elsa Beauford all right Thank
You chairman um I will be voting for the
motion tonight no secret about that and
to me I said it before I still don't
really understand what all the fuss is
about
because if there is the disqualification
or certain member dies or moves doesn't
attend for six months or whatever or
resigns then a vacancy is created and
all that's happening here is that we're
being asked to delegate the chief
executive the task of declaring that
vacancy not deciding whether there's a
vacancy or not declaring it so to me
it's a simple administrative legally
required action that sensibly just gets
carried out automatically now our own
lawyers have been working overtime this
afternoon and pointing out that we if we
pass this tonight we'll be out of step
with Dover District Council and it's
absolutely right
we will however we will be in step with
Midway Council with mates and counsel
with Ada and Worthing counts of West
Berkshire and I could go on the fact is
to me I think this is a very sensible
thing to do streamlined work in this
council stops the politics coming in to
what is a very simple legally required
administrative function so I would
definitely be voting for it Thank You
chaos of a third councillor Johnson
thank you very much chairman as I've
previously said I will be voting against
this mostly because of my experience of
this council but also under one point
one in the introduction to this it
refers to a vacancy in office where a
councillor ceases to be qualified as a
member becomes disqualified for being a
member or ceases to be a member by
reason of failure to attend meetings it
has to be someone's info
perhaps with outside counsel advice that
we should be seeing in writing how
someone becomes disqualified I don't
think it should be the opinion of one
person albeit the elevator chief
executive of counsel to decide what
makes a person disqualified being
disqualified can be that you have gone
to prison you've done something dreadful
or being disqualified could be that you
were seconded to a job where you were
told by that council you were perfectly
entitled to take that we're going over
old ground this is some this is nothing
to do with the disqualification as has
been explained kelsa fella is just
quoted if there is disqualification now
how do we know how the decision to
disqualify a councillor has been has
been made what evidence do the
councillors have that be a
disqualification is valid if we're going
to go immediately to delegated power I
don't see that as part of this evening's
agenda item if exactly what I'm talking
about because our councillors would not
be in a situation given the evidence
what what backs the decision to
disqualify I don't think I've seen the
evidence I don't think any of the
councillors and that is a totally
different item that's outside this
chamber being dealt with by other courts
not this one councillor Piper Thank You
mr. chairman I sincerely wish we were
not having this debate tonight but
circumstances
have led us where we are today it is
important that we only debate the agenda
item that's in front of us with that in
mind mr. chairman I'd like to say that
those same circumstances that have
brought us here have caused me to do a
great deal of reflection and come to the
conclusion that such an important though
legal matter as declaring a casual
vacancy in this council should remain
within the responsibility of the elected
members our Constitution part three
delegation scheme item 37 refers perhaps
members were not fully aware and I
certainly had not fully realized it that
such responsibility has in fact always
been ours I thought it has nothing to do
with us if it was a legal matter but in
fact it has been ours always mr.
chairman is it just a legal matter to be
handled by lawyers or is it a matter
that should be fully discussed with all
relevant information and the decision to
declare taken by full counsel because
that's what this debate is about tonight
do we delegate or do we not we have a
bit of a problem because if we do not
delegate the powers of seating those
members who voted against the motion on
the 15th of October apparently will be
called to the High Court to explain
their actions as a result of a report
having to be filed by our monitoring
officer under Section 5 of the local
government and Housing Act 1989 it has
been mentioned by councillor Johnson
earlier a casual vacancy occurs when an
elected member ceases to be an elected
member as a result of for example their
death resignation becoming disqualified
or being no longer qualified to remain
elected could members please be given
more definitive information regarding
the responsibilities of Decorah
declaration when to declare and when not
to so that we can make an informed
decision regarding the possible
designation of responsibilities and know
exactly what it is we are being asked to
delegate is there in fact a simple legal
phrase which explains when to declare
and when
- I ask because the electoral commission
over several phone calls and emails
yesterday and today are unable to advise
me on the legal position I know it's a
big ass but we're only laypeople
I think we need to be fully informed
Thank You mr. chairman Thank You
councillor Piper and I'm informed that
will be the subject of a totally
separate members briefing councillor
Constantine you spoken once do we have a
new item to discuss on the agenda item
Thank You chair you've you're always
very harsh with me chair I'm not sure I
always deserve it actually but I just
wanted to say that both staff and
council constant silence I've been told
you've spoken on this agenda item
previously so can you please sit down
thank you I just want you to know that's
both staff and public feel that too many
powers have been handed to the chief X
thank you thank you very much noted
councillor Wells I'd like to move on to
the vote
OTT soon as possible sure you what mr.
chair I'm sure I won't give any headache
the phrase that stuck in my mind from
the emails we've received was that the
legal requirement is to declare a
vacancy as soon as is practicable so
you're headed missed has taught me to
read back your email that includes that
phrase I start forthwith so can you
please give me the correct rate isn't
all use of correct phrase the regs you
believe clear forthwith so did I dream
your use of the word practical in that
looks like I did okay well in my dream
your email mentioned practicable and if
the Constitution requirement is that
members approve then Julie within that
definition of practical is being able to
secure a majority and the grubbing truth
about our presence here tonight is that
actually we are being asked to make a
decision because it would appear that
the correct vote wasn't undertaken it
reminds me of something that's going on
at a national level and requirements to
keep voting until the right that comes
up if that is the situation and if we
have a forthcoming piece of training to
assist us in this decision it's asking
an awful lot of us to make that decision
before we have been properly and fully
trained when we will be practicably
prepared for the decision it's not
training it's a briefing Kelsch a matter
face Thank You chair in this sense we've
got elected in 2015 we've had eight
by-elections I think that's the number
the previous term we had two they were
all declared by I'm assumed the chief
executive at asking the electoral
services manager to do so so I can't
understand what is - why if they were
delegated to the chief executive then
why do we need to actually vote to
delegate them to the chief executive I
need to ask what is different between
the various by-elections we've had in
the last three and a half years and this
particular one this vacancy that wasn't
declared I'm a little bit confused if
the Constitution as is written says that
the chief executive doesn't declare them
or the council declares them surely we
should if I clarification on the eight
previous councils or has the chief
executive declared them without
reference to the right kind of body I'm
a little bit confused on that I would be
monitoring office to explain face thank
you yes the chief yet Eve already has
powers in relation to our Baker's issue
it's arrived through death or
resignation that's already delegated
what we're asking for here is the
circumstances set out in section 86
which are set out in the
I'm sorry but you haven't answered my
question because we have had members
disqualified for not attending for six
months no we did have an officer will
clarify somebody who's just qualified
for not attending for six months because
they were otherwise detained but I
didn't come I don't have cold that
coming to Council yes there was a
situation where two counselors and
failed to attend meetings for getting on
for six months very close to six months
but prior to that six months expiring
they resigned the one who was otherwise
detained at her majesty's pleasure i
mean that vacancy was declared and i
don't recall
i don't call the actual circumstances
been that one SPO before the memory
banks of one brain sleeps together i
think he did resign before it came
before for counseling thank you
okay we'll move to the vote if we can
move to vote now all those in favor of
the original proposal as read out
okay thank you
those against
abstentions that motions lost and that
concludes the business for the meeting
of the council this evening thank you